(audience applauding)
- Wait, okay, so the
big game is this Sunday.
- [Stephen] Yes.
- I'm aware, I think you're
going for the Eagles down there,
young Dylan, okay.
- You know, you know.
- [Kelly] Okay, whatever.
- Yes, he's got other problems
- Okay.
to deal with after the show.
- I'm going for the Kansas City Chiefs
because they have great initials.
That's why I'm doing it.
(Kelly chuckling)
- You know, listen, it's
gonna be a great Super Bowl
because Patrick Mahomes
is something special.
He's something sensational,
and so is Travis Kelsey.
I mean, we talk so much
about Patrick Mahomes
but Travis Kelsey is one
of the best tight ends in
the history of football.
He is phenomenal, and he's a
future hall of famer as well.
So they're gonna have something
to say about the outcome.
But I think when you look at the Eagles
there are no weak spots.
- They've got a great record.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- There are no weak spots.
- [Stephen] It's hard to imagine
The Philadelphia Eagles, they could lose,
but I wouldn't bet against them.
- [Kelly] All right.
I'm going to, for fun.
- [Stephen] Okay.
All right.
How much money you bet?
- I don't know.
You want to make a bet?
- [Stephen] All right.
You bet dinner or something like that?
Well, what bet you want?
I'm going to-
I'll bet Kelly Clarkson.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I'll bet Kelly Clarkson.
- Okay, wait, wait, wait.
- All right.
I'll do that.
- If the Chiefs, if the Chiefs win
you have to come on here
and say you love the Dallas Cowboys.
(Kelly giggling)
And if the Eagles win
I have to come on your
show and do something...
- [Stephen] That's right.
- embarrassing.
- [Stephen] Well, let's do it this way.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I'll take that bet.
- Okay.
Okay.
What do I have to do?
- If the Eagles win this Super Bowl...
- [Kelly] Uh-huh.
- You don't have to be a song.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I want you to sing a tune dedicated
to Stephen A. Smith, the straight shooter.
(Kelly laughing and applauding)
(audience cheering)
- I'll take it.
I'll take it.
Oh my God, come on, Chiefs!
(audience laughing)
Do this for me!